hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the impromptu
speech that Alcibiades delivers at the
very end of the symposium in a drunken
state one of the key themes has to do
with Socrates and it turns on a metaphor
about this what we're going to talk
about the Salinas statute the real
contrast that's going on there is
between inside and outside or the
internal and the external the private
the Riedl and the public the only
apparent and Elsa findings is going to
say that socrates has a particularly
complex relationship between these which
he himself has been able to come to know
firsthand and he's going to tell us
about
so he said socrates is like those
Salinas statues and if you've ever seen
a image of Socrates youyou can see that
he not only is a pretty ugly guy he's
pretty ugly in a rather specific way
Salinas was a satyr he's one of these
you know legendary half man half
these kind of creatures and it's kind of
an ugly looking thing right and he
represents the forces of nature or the
old gods or you know the verdicts can't
have enough there's a rather there's too
many different verdicts on that he says
sorry this looks like one of those
things but it happens
the statues that they had were kind of
tricky because on the outside they would
look rather plain and uncommon and ugly
but we would open them up they had
little images golden images of the gods
of the beautiful Greek gods inside so
the metaphor here is that Socrates
himself is he's got this external
appearance what it is that people think
about him as a public figure but none of
that's really the case that's all just
sort of for show and inside is where the
real action is because there's beautiful
wonderful things but you've gotta open
him up first before you can see that
sort of thing
so how can is Socrates like this
Alcibiades doesn't fully develop the
metaphor you know perhaps because he's
drunk because you know that's the way
Plato intends him to be in this case but
you know drugging this is probably a
metaphor for Alcibiades in temperance
and impatience anyway he does develop
several of the we might stay share the
attributes that are making this metaphor
work one of these is that Salinas was
supposed to have been a musician and
like musicians he would stir up the soul
he would charm or soothe or arouse or
you know all sorts of other action words
we could say the souls of those who are
listening to the music
now Salinas would play a flute there are
other musical instruments that were used
and then of course there's the voice and
there's this entire tradition in Greece
of epic poetry which was not just
recited but actually song as well so
there's this entire musical tradition to
draw on and music we know stirs the
purse
we see this in plato's other dialogues
there was a common place among the
Greeks Socrates is a musician but
Socrates
unlike other musicians doesn't need an
instrument as a matter of fact his voice
is not even an instrument in the way
that other musicians are were they
saying
and there's tones in the voice Socrates
just needs words and with those words
Socrates can totally captivate an
audience he can perplex them he control
them he can you know leave them desiring
more the often does leave that desiring
more he can make them totally
you know confused he can illuminate them
so Socrates is likes the lesson that
he's got that going for him another way
in which he's very much like Salinas
according to Elsa bias has to do with
what we call Socratic irony and a
granita doesn't mean the kind of irony
that we talked about today was oh that's
ironic that you know I wouldn't say
poetic justice happens right the person
who is committing the crime gets robbed
himself
we called it ironic the the Greeks
actually called that by it by another
name that Aristotle talks about and
reciprocity literally the same thing
being done and returned to you Socratic
irony it is a different sense of irony
where you're saying something and it
doesn't quite mean what you're saying
there's more than lies beneath there's
more beneath the surface than is there
you know right up front and the
appearances so a Socratic irony exhibits
this dialectic between the internal
which it takes work to get to and the
external and so Socrates overtly will
talk about all sorts of crazy stuff like
cobblers and you know fishermen and pick
whatever you like you know horseshoes
and but inside if you look
his words there's a lot of at least it
seems like wisdom there at the same time
Socrates himself externally is
professing that he does not possess
wisdom or knowledge now all that it
takes is reading a platonic dialogue
rather closely and you will see that
there's a lot of places in the dialogue
where Socrates won't be saying that he
doesn't know anything or that you know
they haven't arrived at any sort of
conclusions because he'll be making use
of all sorts of principles that people
agreed here a lot of the way and he'll
also will lead them along how is this
possible somebody like Alcibiades says
if this guy doesn't truly possess any
knowledge or wisdom how does he know
where's the discussion is going how does
he know how to lead people if he himself
doesn't already know the destination
point does Socrates really possess that
that wisdom or knowledge
Alcibiades doesn't know but he suspects
that Socrates is concealing more than
he's actually laying out there
revealing showing to his audience
including Alcibiades so again like none
of the statutes open them up there's
more inside not only Socrates himself
but it's Socrates own words can be
opened up to find another level another
deeper meaning with them there's another
way in which Socrates is like those
statues in which there's a difference
between the inside and the outside as
well ugliness and beauty and this has to
do with the virtues and here's where
Elsa by any speech starts to go a little
bit off the rails right he's going to
talk about temperance that comes up
primarily in terms of the seduction
story that I talked about in the other
core concept video on Alcibiades speech
where Elsa by inez pulls out all the
stops he wants to seduce Socrates he
wants socrates who in fact
appreciate his charms to become his
lover in a very Carlos sense and he you
know goes the whole way and is unable to
pull it off very much like the old you
know sort of silly you know scenario you
know where the student comes into the
professor's office and says you know I
want to talk with you about my grade
I'll do anything anything whatsoever and
then you know they start taking off some
of their clothes Alcibiades goes even
further than that
he gets naked it lays down next to
Socrates and tell Socrates you're the
only person that's worthy of my love the
only person that really deserves me to
give myself to you and Socrates says
well let me consider that sometime and
then when he wakes up the next morning
he says it's as if you know nothing had
happened
because nothing didn't end so Socrates
can display not only temperance of a
normal sort but temperance that goes
above and beyond
he is the period of temperance itself of
moderation of the control over the
bodily appetites for physical pleasures
courage Alcibiades tells this wonderful
story about several different occasions
where he and Socrates were on military
service together there was just
something that you had to do as a man of
a Greek city-state if you were a citizen
you had to be ready to go to war
Socrates actually saves Alcibiades at
one point and here's again where the
internal and external come out Socrates
should have been given the decoration
for valor instead they decided to award
it to Alcibiades who's the one who got
into the problem and who had to be saved
by Socrates they give it to Alcibiades
because they see him as a rising general
and he has family connections and so the
public and the private there's a
discrepancy between the two and
Alcibiades is bringing this out
he says Socrates is totally courageous
now what about the other virtues the
other cardinal virtues
and here's where the speech gets gets
you know much more fragmented we've
already talked about wisdom in terms of
Socratic irony is there a wisdom there
also by these ISM quite sure he thinks
that there is what about justice though
the forth of the traditional four
virtues the cardinal virtues Alcibiades
actually seems to suggest that Socrates
himself is unjust have these in respect
to Alcibiades because he talks about
Socrates as mistreating him and was
treating so many other young men who
Socrates gives attention to and then
these young men you know ended up
instead of being the desired ones end up
being the desires and you know getting
into getting themselves into all sorts
of fits over his ironies he say Socrates
is abusing them now the question that we
should ask is his honor which is really
treating them unjustly or is Socrates
treating them exactly the way that they
deserve he's being temperate in his
relations to them he is offering them a
chance to by engaging with him have some
sort of connection towards wisdom he is
exhorting them to live the better life
it actually appears from Alcibiades
onwards that Socrates is one of the few
beneficial influences on him it's to man
that didn't really work out of Socrates
being able to change Alcibiades
character for the better as it could
have been an incredible asset for the
city
so probably Socrates if we read between
the lines truly does possess justice but
all of that is only apparent if we look
at you know something with it if we
don't just look at appearances if we
look at just the appearances we see the
ugly if we look at the reality that is
much more compelling and is worthwhile
we see Socrates as beautiful